[музика]
Андрій з позивним артист робить свої
перші кроки на протезі він разом із
батьком пішов воювати 24 лютого у
десантно-штурмовій війська а в серпні
підірвався на міні під час контрнаступу
на Херсонщині
у мене дзвін у вухах вибухи ще
довготривали і Буквально через 5 секунд
коли Я повернув головою ліворуч праворуч
почав кричати
кричати від болю бо вже не було правої
ноги і лівою теж майже не було тоже не
було прав ногу ампутували а ліва дуже
травмована її оперували вже кілька разів
тепер Андрій на етапі протезування
до того я дуже переживав я не знав як
зроблю перший крок і коли зробив
звичайно сподобалося
боляче тяжко багато поту виходить знаєте
зараз начебто стаю на тимчасову ногу не
на свою і Таке відчуття ніби мені на
плечі 50-60 кілограмів кидають дуже
сильно хочу додому повноцінно бути вдома
гуляти з дитиною
протезування в Україні є безкоштовним
для усіх як військових так і цивільних
громадян за офіційними даними станом на
червень понад півтисячі українців
потребували протезування та реабілітації
через втрату кінцівок наразі Україні вже
потрібно удвічі більше фахівців у галузі
протезування визнають в уряді близько
півсотні наявних центрів перевантажені
про стрімке збільшення кількості Запитів
та черги на протезування розповідають і
в центрі протезування аутизування і
реабілітації без обмежень якщо брати
14-й рік це були мінно вибухові
поранення якісь прильоти були режими
затишшями режими тиші перемир'я якісь
той час це активна фаза нон-стоп і
кожного дня На жаль люди отримують
якийсь от травми у центрі з
представництвами У дев'яти містах
цивільним у межах державної програми
пропонують протези для ходьби та
плавання а військовим ще й
високофункціональні спортивні наш
військові ну 50%. це точно
вертається на фронт
і не то що там там десь сидять пісяють
чи хто а він воює по повній програмі від
водолазів до
глубинная разведка
дуже багато людей Вони роблять своє діло
їхати за якісними протезами за кордон не
обов'язково фахівці вже навчилися
збирати їх в Україні комплектуючи
підбирають із найкращих у світі якщо
найкраще ми знаємо стопа в Америці ми їх
куповуємо в Америці якщо найкраще там
коліна гідравлічні в Англії ми його
купуємо в Англії якщо найкращий клапан
протяжка був модуль або будь-яка деталь
в Германії ми в якому купуємо Германії
основні країни яким віддаємо пріоритет
це Англія
Германія Бельгія Швеція Америка Японія
тобто найкраще що я в світовій протезній
галузі ми черпаємо звідти ставимо на
наші хлопці та дівчат з наступного року
у центрі планують виготовляти навіть
біонічні руки де окремо рухається кожен
палиці можна давати фізичні навантаження
на нову ногу в центрі протезування чекає
і морпіх Олексій із 503 окремого
батальйону чоловік втратив власну під
штурму на Донеччині Але після
протезування хоче продовжувати службу я
скажу що протести не так страшно Я
считаю 21 рік технології тіпа І если в
тебе друга нога буде от Желізна то це
наоборот даже кручу чим тебе обичних
надо шукати позитив я от такі знайшов
позитивну даже не то що знайшов позитив
я наоборотну горжуть що типа в мене буде
друга отака ногами ще буду нестандартним
человеком щоб знову поставити людей на
ноги у майстерні трудиться Володимир
Федоров Він працює технікум протезистом
вже 43 роки ми приймаємо людину
проходять огляд
як огляд прийшов да Якщо йому можна ми
робимо гіпсовий слід беремо цей гіпсовий
Сліпа заливаємо гіпсом получається
отакий був негатив став позитив оцей от
позитив Я повинен вігнати в його розміри
Я пам'ятаю дуже добре Де я його всі
болючі місця кожен протез виготовляють
індивідуальну спочатку роблять гіпсовий
зліпок потім модель кукси кінцівка яка
залишилася після ампутації а далі
куксуприймач вже його кріплять до заліза
бо вложити в душу протез якщо вона так
не вкладається от робиш Ну як конвеєр
вона нічого не буде
тут треба трошки попохтіти
попотіти і тоді щось получиться це не
так просто
90%
всього це модель як зняв модель як її
зробив от зробив модельку гарно для
людині сидить
ніде не давить ніде не душить ніде не
натирає він
комфортно себе почуває
то це да оце от успіх
став і пішов останній день
щоправда ходити захисників доводиться
буквально вчити заново свої перші кроки
вони роблять під наглядом фізичних
терапевтів і техніків Починаємо ми з
брусів одягаємо протез
спочатку вчимося тримати рівновагу
баланс потім робимо перші кроки навчаємо
їх робити однаковими з якою ноги йти з
протезу здоровою як тримати спину бо ці
навички вони втрачаються за цей час поки
вони в лікарні потім ходять і з паличкою
стають на бігову доріжку і долають сходи
а дехто перелазить через паркани і мріє
зробити сальто на батуті як ото Роман із
початком повномасштабного вторгнення
чоловік пішов в окремий полк
спецпризначення азов-київ під час штурму
ворожих позицій на сході потрапив під
обстріл із танка осколок від снаряда
розірвав ногу
Я досить недавно почав на ньому вже
бігати перед цим я не міг ще не були
готові м'язи я можу боксувати на нього
тобто займатися боксом
вільно пересуватися перелазити вже якісь
забори і тому подібне ну досить активно
я півтора місяці Лежу на протезі і можу
собі дозволити вже деякі речі не просто
ходити як зроблять вже новий
культіприйомник я піду на батути пригати
вже протезі
[музика]